LADIES AND GENTLEMEN AT THIS
TIME PLEASE RISE FOR THE
PRESENTATION OF THE COLORS BY
THE MIT HONOR GUARD AND REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE CONCERT CHOIR
IN SINGING THE NATIONAL ANTHEM.
♪
♪ O SAY CAN YOU SEE BY THE
DAWN'S EARLY LIGHT ♪
♪ WHAT SO PROUDLY WE HAILED AT
THE TWILIGHT'S LAST GLEAMING ♪
♪ WHOSE BROAD STRIPES AND
BRIGHT STARS THROUGH THE
PERILOUS FIGHT ♪
♪ O'ER THE RAMPARTS WE WATCHED
WERE SO GALLANTLY STREAMING ♪
♪ AND THE ROCKETS RED GLARE ♪
♪ THE BOMBS BURSTING IN AIR ♪
♪ GAVE PROOF THROUGH THE NIGHT ♪
♪ THAT THE FLAG WAS STILL THERE
♪ O SAY DOES THAT STAR-SPANGLED
BANNER YET WAVE ♪
♪ O'ER THE LAND OF THE FREE ♪
♪ AND THE HOME OF THE BRAVE ♪ ♪
PLEASE BE SEATED.
GOOD MORNING AND WELCOME TO THE
DEDICATION OF THE MEMORIAL TO
MIT POLICE OFFICER SEAN COLLIER,
BADGE 179.
I AM ISRAEL RUIZ, EXECUTIVE VICE
PRESIDENT AND TREASURER AT MIT.
IT IS OUR HONOR TO BE JOINED
TODAY BY:
THE COLLIER AND ROGERS FAMILY;
ATTORNEY GENERAL MAURA HEALEY;
US ATTORNEY CARMEN ORTIZ;
MIDDLESEX DISTRICT ATTORNEY
MARIAN RYAN;
AND MANY FRIENDS FROM THE CITY
OF CAMBRIDGE, INCLUDING MAYOR
DAVID MAHER;
CITY MANAGER RICH ROSSI;
AND CAMBRIDGE POLICE
COMMISSIONER BOB HAAS, WHO HAVE
BEEN BY OUR SIDE EVERY STEP OF
THE WAY.
IT IS A PRIVILEGE TO HAVE WITH
US:
CITY COUNCILORS...
LELAND CHEUNG
CRAIG KELLEY
NADEEM MAZEN
MARC MCGOVERN
AND TIM TOOMEY.
I WOULD ALSO LIKE TO WELCOME
MASSACHUSETTS STATE COLONEL
TIMOTHY ALBEN AND THE ALL
MEMBERS OF LAW ENFORCEMENT
AGENCIES JOINING US IN SUPPORT
AND FRIENDSHIP.
TO THE MEMBERS OF THE MIT
COMMUNITY: WE HAVE STOOD STRONG
IN THE TWO YEARS SINCE WE LOST
OFFICER COLLIER ON THAT TRAGIC
NIGHT IN APRIL 2013.
TODAY, WE GATHER TO REMEMBER
OFFICER COLLIER AND TO THANK THE
COLLIER MEMORIAL PROJECT TEAM,
AND THE MEMORIAL COMMITTEE
CO-CHAIRED BY CHIEF JOHN DIFAVA
AND PROVOST MARTY SCHMIDT, ALL
OF WHOM PERSEVERED THROUGH THE
WINTER WITH VISION, COMMITMENT,
AND TIRELESS EFFORT TO BRING US
TO THIS DAY.
YOU WILL FIND THE LIST OF
CONTRIBUTORS IN YOUR PROGRAM,
BUT PLEASE ALLOW ME TO THANK A
FEW INDIVIDUALS.
THE MIT COMMUNITY IS ENORMOUSLY
GRATEFUL TO PROFESSOR MEEJIN
YOON, HEAD OF MIT'S DEPARTMENT
OF ARCHITECTURE FOR HER IMMENSE
CREATIVITY, SENSITIVITY, AND
LEADERSHIP, AND TO THE WHOLE
DESIGN TEAM AT HÖWELER AND YOON.
TO PROFESSOR JOHN OCHSENDORF AND
HIS ENGINEERING COLLEAGUES, WE
EXPRESS AWE AND GRATITUDE FOR
THE ARTFULLY PRECISE WORK THAT
ALLOWED DESIGN TO BECOME
REALITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK SUFFOLK
CONSTRUCTION AND THE WHOLE TEAM
OF DEDICATED PROFESSIONALS WHO
SURMOUNTED EXTRAORDINARY
CHALLENGES OF WEATHER AND
LOGISTICS PRECEDING THIS DAY,
WITH PARTICULAR APPRECIATION TO
ROB ROGERS, WHO IS BOTH PROJECT
MANAGER AND SEAN'S
BROTHER...ROB,
WE ARE PROUD TO HAVE WORKED WITH
YOU.
AND TO THE MIT PROJECT TEAM, LED
BY RICHARD AMSTER, PAUL MURPHY,
AND JENNIFER COMBS: THANK YOU.
YOUR PERSONAL COMMITMENT HAS
MADE IT POSSIBLE TO OPEN THE
MEMORIAL TO OUR COMMUNITY TODAY.
THE PERMANENT MEMORIAL IS
INTENDED TO BE A PLACE OF
REMEMBRANCE AND REFLECTION, A
PLACE THAT EVOKES THE STRENGTH
OF 'COLLIER STRONG', A PLACE
THAT REFLECTS THE CONNECTEDNESS
OF OUR COMMUNITY, AND EPITOMIZES
THE HIGHEST EXPRESSION OF OUR
MIT MOTTO 'MENS ET MANUS' --
MIND AND HAND.
I KNOW THAT THE MEMORIAL, WITH
ITS POWERFUL DESIGN, WITH WHAT
IT REPRESENTS AND ALL THAT IT
SIGNIFIES, WILL PROVIDE A PLACE
WHERE WE CAN GO TO CELEBRATE
OFFICER COLLIER'S LIFE, TO SHARE
HIS SENSE OF COMMUNITY, TO FEEL
A SENSE OF PROTECTION, A PLACE
WHERE AN OPEN HAND REMINDS US
THAT WE ARE A COMMUNITY THAT
STAYS TRUE TO ITS HIGHEST VALUES
AND REACHES OUT TO THOSE IN NEED
AS OFFICER COLLIER DID, EVEN IN
THE FACE OF THE ULTIMATE THREAT.
THE COLLIER MEMORIAL AND THE
PEOPLE WHO MADE IT POSSIBLE
REPRESENT THE BEST EMBODIMENT
AND TRIBUTE TO OFFICER COLLIER'S
LIFE, AND MAKE MIT VERY PROUD.
IT IS NOW MY PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE MIT PRESIDENT, RAFAEL
REIF.
[APPLAUSE]
THANK YOU, ISRAEL.
SINCE WE LOST OFFICER COLLIER
TWO YEARS AGO, YOU HAVE PLAYED A
CENTRAL ROLE IN GUIDING OUR
COMMUNITY'S RESPONSE.
MOST RECENTLY, TOGETHER WITH
YOUR TEAM, YOU OVERSAW THE
CREATION OF THIS SUPERB
MEMORIAL.
AND I WANT TO EXPRESS MY
GRATITUDE FOR YOUR INSPIRED
LEADERSHIP.
GOOD MORNING, OFFICER COLLIER'S
FAMILY, MAYOR MAHER AND OUR MANY
DISTINGUISHED GUESTS.
PROFESSOR YOON, PROFESSOR
OCHSENDORF AND THE ENTIRE
MEMORIAL TEAM.
CHIEF DIFAVA...AND SEAN'S
COUNTLESS FRIENDS AND ADMIRERS,
IN AND OUT OF UNIFORM.
WE COME TOGETHER AT THE END OF A
LONG WINTER.
BUT TODAY, IN THE WARMTH OF EACH
OTHER'S COMPANY...AND THROUGH
THE BRIGHT MEMORY OF SEAN'S
EXAMPLE...I BELIEVE WE HAVE
FOUND SPRING AT LAST.
THIS MORNING I WANT TO MAKE TWO
OBSERVATIONS ABOUT THE MEMORIAL
ITSELF AND WHAT IT EXPRESSES
ABOUT OUR COMMUNITY.
IN A MOMENT, THE DESIGNER OF THE
MONUMENT, PREFER -- PROFESSOR
MEEJIN YOON WILL DESCRIBE HOW IT
WAS MADE.
AND WE WILL HEAR ABOUT THE
IMPULSE, THE INSTINCT TO DO IT
YOURSELF.
THIS MEMORIAL WAS DESIGNED AND
ENGINEERED BY A BRILLIANT TEAM
OF MIT FACULTY STUDENTS AND
STAFF.
THEY WERE MOVED TO BE A PART OF
THE PROCESS, AND WERE PERSONALLY
INVESTED IN THE OUTCOME.
AND IN LEADING THE TEAM FROM
SUFFOLK CONSTRUCTION, SEAN'S
BROTHER, ROB, MADE EVERYONE FEEL
LIKE FAMILY.
THIS WAS NOT A PROJECT PRODUCED
AT THE REQUEST OF A PATRON.
INSTEAD IT WAS AN OFFERING
INTENDED FOR ALL OF US.
AN EXPLORATION OF THEMES AND
FORMS AND EMOTIONS AND MEMORIES,
MATERIALS AND FORCES.
A CREATIVE EXPERIMENT FORMED BY
OUR COMMUNITY AND FOR OUR
COMMUNITY.
IT WAS AN ACT OF TRANSFORMATION.
MIT IS KNOWN FOR SCIENCE AND
TECHNOLOGY, DISCOVERY AND
INNOVATION.
BOLDNESS AND DARING.
TODAY THROUGH THIS MEMORIAL WE
DEMONSTRATE ALL OF THOSE
STRENGTHS AND WE REMIND
OURSELVES OF OUR CAPACITY FOR
REVERENCE AND BEAUTY TOO.
WE ARE A COMMUNITY OF MAKERS,
AND WE USE THAT POWER TO MAKE
THINGS KNOWN.
A SECOND OBSERVATION, AS WE WILL
HEAR THE STONE ARTIST OF THE
MEMORIAL ARE HELD TOGETHER NOT
WITH MORTAR OR FASTENERS BUT
SHEER FAITH IN THE POWER OF
PHYSICS.
THOSE ARE FORCES THAT WE
UNDERSTAND VERY WELL AT MIT, AND
MOST TIMES AND PLACES.
THESE FORCES ARE INVISIBLE.
BUT THIS MEMORIAL REVEALS THEM
TO THE WORLD BY DISPLAYING THEIR
POWER IN ACTION.
TWO YEARS AGO AS WE FIRST
MOURNED OFFICER COLLIER, THE
MEMBERS OF OUR COMMUNITY CAME
TOGETHER WITH INCREDIBLE
STRENGTH, MORE THAN WE HAD
UNDERSTOOD WAS POSSIBLE.
WE CAME TOGETHER IN DEEP
SYMPATHY FOR SEAN'S FAMILY AND
POLICE AND FIRST RESPONDERS
AND EMPATHY FOR EVERYONE
THAT ENDURED THE TRAUMA OF THE
BOSTON BOMBINGS.
WE SAW COURAGE AND GENEROSITY
AND ENDURANCE, QUALITIES ALWAYS
THERE BUT NOT USUALLY REVEALED.
UNTIL WE ALL UNDERSTOOD WHAT IT
MEANT TO BE COLLIER STRONG.
IN EFFECT, WE SAW THEN THAT WE
ARE HELD TOGETHER BY INVISIBLE
FORCES TOO.
THE TRAGEDY OF SEAN'S LOSS MADE
THOSE FORCES VISIBLE AND MADE
THEM STRONGER.
BEGINNING TODAY, THIS MEMORIAL
WILL BE A LANDMARK IN OUR DAILY
LIVES.
AND A GATEWAY TO THE CAMPUS WE
SHARE.
AND I HOPE THAT IN ITS GRACEFUL
DISPLAY OF INVISIBLE PHYSICAL
FORCES, IT CAN BECOME A DAILY
REMINDER OF THOSE INVISIBLE
HUMAN FORCES THAT CREATE
COMMUNITY.
I HOPE IT CAN SERVE AS A GATEWAY
TO THE KNOWLEDGE OF
EXTRAORDINARY THINGS WE CAN
ACHIEVE IF WE CAN SEE AND FEEL
AND DRAW ON THAT POWER TOGETHER.
WITHOUT CALAMITY TO CONFRONT
OTHER CHALLENGES FOR EACH OTHER,
FOR OUR COMMUNITY, OUR CITY, OUR
NATION, OUR WORLD.
WE DEDICATE THIS MEMORIAL TO A
YOUNG MAN WHO BY THE JOYFUL WAY
HE LIVED SHOWED US WHAT IT MEANS
TO BE ONE MIT, AND ONE
COMMUNITY.
TODAY INSPIRED BY HIS EXAMPLE,
MAY WE FIND THAT THE POWER TO
ENDURE TOGETHER HAS BECOME THE
POWER TO HEAL, TO GATHER OUR
FORCES AND TO BEGIN TO GROW
AGAIN.
NOW FOR A PERSPECTIVE FROM OUR
COMMENDED COMMUNITY, IT IS NOW
MY PLEASURE TO INTRODUCE OUR
GOOD FRIEND AND NEIGHBOR, THE
MAYOR OF THE CITY OF CAMBRIDGE,
DAVID MAHER.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESIDENT REIF, AND VICE
PRESIDENT RUIZ, AND CHIEF DIFAVA
AND MEMBERS OF THE COLLIER
FAMILY AND MEMBERS OF THE MIT
COMMUNITY.
GOOD AFTERNOON, IT'S AN HONOR TO
BE WITH YOU TODAY.
ON BEHALF OF MY COLLEAGUES IN
LOCAL GOVERNMENT AND THE
RESIDENCES OF THE GREAT CITY OF
CAMBRIDGE, I STAND BEFORE YOU
TODAY TO OFFER OUR CONTINUED
HEART FELT PRAYERS TO SEAN AND
HIS FAMILY.
AND TO THE POLICE DEPARTMENT AND
THE COMMUNITY AND TO ALL OFFICER
COLLIER'S COLLEAGUES IN THE LAW
ENFORCEMENT, AND THE CAMBRIDGE
POLICE DEPARTMENT AND THE
CAMBRIDGE FIRE DEPARTMENT WITH
US TODAY.
A YEAR AGO I HAD THE HONOR OF
MARKING THE ONE YEAR ANNIVERSARY
OF OFFICER COLLIER'S TRAGIC
PASSING.
IT'S HARD TO BELIEVE THAT
ANOTHER YEAR HAS PASSED.
TODAY WE JOIN TOGETHER THE MIT
COMMUNITY, THE CAMBRIDGE
COMMUNITY, AND THE LARGER
GREATER BOSTON COMMUNITY TO
HONOR THE MEMORY OF OFFICER SEAN
COLLIER.
IN THE DAYS AND WEEKS AFTER
OFFICER COLLIER'S DEATH, OUR
COMMUNITIES DISPLAYED
EXCEPTIONAL COLLABORATION AND
COOPERATION, SUPPORTING EACH
OTHER AND HELPING EACH OTHER
THROUGH WHAT WAS AN
EXTRAORDINARY DIFFICULT AND DARK
PERIOD.
TODAY THOSE BONDS ARE STRONGER
THAN EVER.
AS WE DEDICATE THIS MEMORIAL, I
AM DEEPLY MOVED AND IMPRESSED BY
MIT'S DEPARTMENT OF
ARCHITECTURE, THE COLLIER
MEMORIAL COMMITTEE AND THE
DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION TEAMS.
THIS DEDICATED GROUP OF
INDIVIDUALS COMMITTED THEMSELVES
TO HONORING AND REMEMBERING
OFFICER COLLIER'S LIFE IN HIS
LASTING LEGACY.
THE MEMORIAL COMMITTEE AND THE
ARCHITECTS AND THE MIT COMMUNITY
HAVE FOUND A PERMANENT AND
FITTING WAY TO CAPTURE WHAT IS
COMMONLY REFERRED TO AS COLLIER
STRONG IN THIS BEAUTIFUL
MEMORIAL.
EMPHASIZING STRENGTH AND UNITY.
THE DEDICATION OF THIS MEMORIAL
ENSURES THAT OFFICER COLLIER'S
MEMORY WILL NEVER BE FORGOTTEN.
THIS MEMORIAL WILL SERVE AS A
SYMBOL OF STRENGTH, COURAGE,
SERVICE AND DEDICATION.
ALL QUALITIES THAT SEAN EMBODIED
BOTH AS A POLICE OFFICER, AND
MORE IMPORTANTLY AS A HUMAN
BEING.
THE DESIGN OF THE MEMORIAL
SYMBOLIZES HOW WE ARE UNITED AS
ONE COMMUNITY.
THE WALLS SEEMINGLY REACH OUT
BEYOND THE MIT CAMPUS TO THE
CAMBRIDGE COMMUNITY AS ONE.
MEMORIAL SERVES AS A PERMANENT
WAY TO REMEMBER OFFICER COLLIER
A TRIBUTE TO A LIFE OF SERVICE,
DEDICATION AND SACRIFICE.
THE SHEER SIZE AND IMPOSING
DESIGN OF THE MEMORIAL ENSURE
THAT ALL WHO PASS BY THIS SITE.
WHETHER THIS WEEK OR DAYS FROM
NOW OR DECADES FROM NOW, KNOW
WHO OFFICER COLLIER WAS AND THE
SPIRIT HE EMBODIED.
THOUGH WE WILL NEVER FORGET THE
TRAGIC EVENTS OF TWO YEARS AGO,
THIS MEMORIAL SERVES AS A
REMINDER OF GOOD.
A REMINDER OF AN EXTRAORDINARY
YOUNG MAN WHO WAS FULL OF LIFE
AND LOVE AND COMMITTED TO
SERVING OTHERS.
IN CLOSING I WANT TO THANK THE
MIT COMMUNITY AND THE COLLIER
FAMILY.
AND I WANT YOU ALL TO KNOW THAT
THE CITY OF CAMBRIDGE AND OUR
RESIDENTS CONTINUE TO STAND WITH
YOU AND CONTINUE TO BE INSPIRED
BY YOUR STRENGTH AND GRACE.
THANK YOU.
[APPLAUSE]
HERE WE ARE
A CONVERGENCE OF SEEKERS,
SERVERS, SPEAKERS, MAKERS.
ALONE WE CARRY INDIVIDUAL
FLAMES; TOGETHER WE BECOME A
RADIANT CONSTELLATION HONORING
SEAN COLLIER.
FOR MANY OF US, SEAN WAS A
SOURCE OF LIGHT, A SOURCE OF
WARMTH.
HE TALKED TO US, HIKED WITH US,
DANCED WITH US.
HE WAS ALWAYS AMONG US.
HE STILL IS.
TAKE A LOOK AROUND.
WE COME ALSO TO HONOR THE
RECENTLY LOST, FELLOW STUDENTS
AND FRIENDS, FOR EVERY LOSS
LEAVES A VOID.
LET OUR PRIVATE SORROWS BECOME
AS PUBLIC AS AIR, AS FUNCTIONAL
AS GRANITE.
THE WORLD TELLS US WE ARE
FINITE, BUT OUR INFINITE
INCLINATIONS WILL TOUCH
MOUNTAINTOPS, OCEAN FLOORS, THE
EDGE OF THIS WORLD, AND THE
HORIZONS OF HUMAN EXPERIENCE.
HERE WE ARE NOT ALONE.
HERE WE LEARNED TO HACK OUR WAY
INTO EACH OTHER'S HEARTS.
TOGETHER WE STEP OUT OF THE
SHADOWS, EACH OF OUR LIVES ITS
OWN LIGHT SOURCE, ELEVATING
EVERY LIFE WE TOUCH.
TWO YEARS AGO WE WERE SHELTERING
IN PLACE; TODAY WE CELEBRATE A
PLACE OF SHELTER.
TAKE A LOOK AROUND.
OPEN HEART.
OPEN MIND.
OPEN HAND.
[APPLAUSE]
PRESIDENT REIF, AND MEMBERS
OF THE COLLIER AND ROGER FAMILY,
HONORED GUESTS AND MEMBERS OF
THE MIT FAMILY AND FAMILY AND
FRIENDS, GOOD AFTERNOON.
WE HAVE SPOKE A NUMBER OF WORDS
AND CRIED A RIVER OF TEARS, TO
HONOR SEAN'S MEMORY.
BUT THERE IS ANOTHER REASON WHY
WE EXPRESS SUCH DEEP AND
HEART-FELT EMOTION, TO REACH OUT
AND FIND THE COMFORT AND SUPPORT
WE NEED TO DEAL WITH A SITUATION
THAT IS IMPOSSIBLE TO
UNDERSTAND, NEVER MIND ACCEPT.
IMMEDIATELY AFTER THE SHELTER IN
PLACE WAS LIVED BY THE GOVERNOR
ON APRIL 19, THIS PLACE BECAME A
MEMORIAL.
PEOPLE IN AND OUTSIDE OF THE
INSTITUTE WERE CALLED TO THE
SITE OF SEAN'S DEATH TO MAKE
SENSE OF A TRAGEDY THAT MADE NO
SENSE.
STUFFED ANIMALS OF EVERY VARIETY
AND FLOWERS AND LETTERS, AND
CARDS AND PICTURES AND THE
OCCASIONAL BASEBALL CAP WERE THE
ATTEMPTS FROM SO MANY PEOPLE
TRYING TO MANIFEST THEIR
FEELINGS IN TANGIBLE FORM, WHILE
ASKING THE SAME QUESTION, WHY.
AS WEEKS AND MONTHS WENT BY,
THIS TEMPORARY REMEMBRANCE WAS
WOVEN INTO THE FAMILY OF MIT.
AND ALL HOURS OF THE SACRED
NIGHT, GROUPS CAME ALONE OR
HOLDING HANDS, AND DEEP IN
THOUGHT AND EYES DOWN AND
THOUGHTS ONLY TO THEM THEY CAME.
ONE COMMON THOUGHT, TO REMEMBER.
MANY KNEW SEAN BUT MOST DID NOT.
FOR THEY CAME OUT OF RESPECT.
TO PRAY AND FIND COMFORT IN THE
PRESENCE OF OTHERS.
IT WAS ALL WE HAD, AND IT SERVED
US WELL, FOR PROVIDED A SENSE OF
STABILITY IN THOSE SAD AND
UNCERTAIN TIMES.
BUT NOW WE HAVE MORE, SO VERY
MUCH MORE.
SOMETHING BEYOND ALL OF OUR
EXPECTATIONS.
HOWEVER WE MUST UNDERSTAND THAT
THIS WONDERFUL MEMORIAL THAT WE
DEDICATE TODAY IS NOT MEANT TO
REPLACE WHAT WAS SPONTANEOUS BY
THE LOVE OF THE COMMUNITY BUT
CONTINUATION OF THAT LOVE IN A
PERMANENT FORM.
MY FATHER WAS BORN IN A CITY
NEAR ITALY, 87 MILES OUTSIDE OF
ROME, AND THOUGH SMALL IN SIZE
IT'S LARGE IN HISTORY.
I REMEMBER VIVIDLY THE FIRST
TIME I VISITED THERE WITH MY
DAD, JULY, 1963, AS WE ENTERED
THE OUTSKIRTS OF THE TOWN IN A
FIAT 500 AND BLOWING SMOKE, I
WAS STRUCK BY THE SUN'S
UNDERSTATED MAJESTY AND SENSE OF
POWER AND PURPOSE, AND ABOVE ALL
THE STRENGTH AND PERMANENCY THAT
THIS STRUCTURE RADIATED.
WITH MY EYES STRUCK ON THIS
OBJECT OF WONDER, I ASKED MY
FATHER WHAT WAS THAT.
HE RESPONDED THAT IS A SITE
BUILT AS A MEMORIAL.
MANY ARCHITECTS AND BUILDERS
MEMORIALS REMAIN WITH US TODAY,
AND THOSE THAT DON'T, FELL BY
THE HANDS OF MAN.
BUT HOWEVER WE HAVE SOMETHING
THAT THE ROMANS DIDN'T HAVE, A
MEEJIN YOON AND JOHN OCHSENDORF
AND MIT.
THIS UNSPOKEN SENSE OF PURPOSE
AND CHARACTER AND ONE OF A KIND
UNIQUENESS REPRESENTS THE
ESSENCE OF WHO SEAN WAS AND WHAT
HE STOOD FOR.
YOU HAVE SURPASSED WHAT WE
EXPECTED.
AND YOU HAVE GIVEN US MORE, WITH
THIS MEMORIAL YOU HAVE GIVEN US
THE STRENGTH AND COURAGE TO PASS
TO HOPE AND OPTIMISM AND LIVE
OUR LIVES IN THE MANNER THAT
SEAN DID EVERY DAY.
WE WILL CRY LESS AND SMILE MORE,
BUT WE ALWAYS REMEMBER.
SARAH FERI, A GRADUATE STUDENT
HERE AT MIT AND A FRIEND OF
SEAN'S, SAID AT THE MEMORIAL
SITE, I WILL NOT SAD WHEN I COME
HERE, THIS MAKES ME HAPPY.
THIS IS THE SENSE OF THIS
MEMORIAL.
I HAVE NO DOUBT IN THE YEARS TO
FOLLOW, WHEN WE ARE LONG GONE,
OTHERS WILL LOOK AT THIS
STRUCTURE, THIS WAS BUILT BY MIT
TO HONOR SEAN COLLIER, AND TO
MIT, HE WAS A GREAT MAN.
IT'S MY PRIDE TO INTRODUCE YOU
TO PROFESSOR MEEJIN YOON.
[APPLAUSE]
THE DESIGN OF THE PERMANENT
MEMORIAL FOR OFFICER SEAN
COLLIER HAS BEEN A DEEPLY
EMOTIONAL AND HUMBLING
EXPERIENCE.
THE COLLIER MEMORIAL IS MANY
THINGS AT ONCE.
A SYMBOL.
A STRUCTURE.
A SPACE.
AS A SYMBOL IT REPRESENTS SEAN'S
SERVICE AND SACRIFICE.
A FIVE-POINTED FIGURE, A STAR,
AND OPEN HAND.
AS A STRUCTURE IT TRANSLATES
COLLIER STRONG INTO A LITERAL
STRUCTURE OF STRENGTH THROUGH
UNITY.
WITH 32 UNIQUE, SOLID GRANITE
BLOCKS TO FORM A FIVE-WAY VAULT.
AS A SPACE, A CENTRAL VOID, A
PLACE OF PAUSE.
AND AN OPEN YET SHELTERED
OUT-DOOR ROOM TO REMEMBER AND
REFLECT.
IT IS A SOLID AND A VOID, HEAVY
AND LIGHT, SIMPLE AND COMPLEX.
A GATEWAY AND A WINDOW.
A ROCK GARDEN AND A MIRROR OF
THE NIGHT SKY.
AND WHILE I HOPE IT BECOMES MANY
THINGS TO MANY PEOPLE.
THE ONE THING THAT CUTS ACROSS
ALL OF THESE METAPHORS AND
REPRESENTATIONS IS THAT IT IS
TRULY MIT.
IN EVERY WAY.
IN ITS APPROACH, IN ITS PROCESS,
AND IN ITS APPLICATION AND
VALUES AND ASPIRATIONS.
THE MEMORIAL PROJECT BROUGHT
TOGETHER ACROSS CAMPUS OVER 100
PEOPLE.
AND THEIR TALENTS AND SKILLS AND
CARE TOGETHER TO SHAPE AND FORM
AND BUILD THE SPECIAL PLACE FOR
THE REMEMBRANCE FOR SEAN.
FROM THE COLLIER COMMITTEES FROM
POLICE OFFICERS AND STUDENT AND
STAFF AND FACULTY.
TO THE MIT MANAGEMENT TEAM TO
THE DESIGN AND CONSTRUCTION
TEAMS AND TO MY COLLEAGUES JOHN
OCHSENDORF, AND TO THE STUDENTS
ACROSS THE DEGREE PROGRAMS AT
MIT.
I HAVE NEVER EXPERIENCED SUCH AN
INCREDIBLE TEAM, THE LEVEL OF
RESPECT, DEDICATION AND CARE
THAT WENT ABOVE AND BEYOND.
THE PROJECT STRETCHED ALL OF US.
AND YET BROUGHT OUT THE BEST IN
EVERYONE.
AND HOW COULD IT NOT?
WITH SEAN'S OWN BROTHER, ROB, ON
THE SITE DAILY AT THE CRACK OF
DAWN.
THROUGH BLIZZARD AFTER BLIZZARD,
DEVOTED AND RESOLVED TO BUILD
BLOCK BY BLOCK TODAY'S MEMORIAL.
IT MUST HAVE BEEN INCREDIBLY
HARD TO WORK SO CLOSE AT THE
SITE WHERE SEAN WAS KILLED.
BUT ROB ALWAYS HAD A KIND SPIRIT
AND CONTAGIOUS SMILE.
AND WHILE NO PHYSICAL STRUCTURE
COULD FULLY REPRESENT THE
FULLNESS OF SEAN'S LIFE AND
MEANING OF HIS LOSS.
FOR THOSE OF US THAT HAD AN
OPPORTUNITY TO LEARN ABOUT SEAN
THROUGH ROB AND JOHN AND SARAH
AND KEVIN AND CHRIS AND SALLY, I
CAN ONLY SAY IT WAS TRULY AN
HONOR.
THE MEMORIAL IN MANY WAYS WAS A
RACE AGAINST TIME TO BUILD A
TIMELESS STRUCTURE.
CONCEPTUALLY RICH.
FORMALLY PRECISE AND TECHNICALLY
UNPRECEDENTED.
A FEW WEEKS AGO ON ATTEMPTS AND
COLD DAY, 30 STUDENTS AND MASONS
AND ARCHITECTS AND ENGINEERS
WERE CRAWLING ON TOP AND
UNDERNEATH AND AROUND THE
MEMORIAL.
FRANTICALLY CHECKING GAUGES AND
SCALES AND LAPTOPS AS EVERYONE
READY TO LOWER THE SCALPEL.
IT WAS A MOMENT OF TRUTH.
AS THE MASONS IN SYNCHRONY
TURNED THE DIALS OF THE SCAFFOLD
LOWERED IN MILLIMETERS FOR
HOURS, I REMEMBER AS THE
STRUCTURE AND THE FORCES MOVED
INTO THE LEGS.
AND EVERYONE CHEERED.
I REMEMBER FEELING A SENSE OF
RELIEF.
BUT ALSO A MOMENT OF PROFOUND
REALIZATION.
THAT THE MEMORIAL HAD NOT BEEN
BUILT REALLY WITH BIG GRANITE
BLOCKS.
BUT HAD IN FACT REALLY BEEN
BUILT WITH BIG HEARTS AND ALL
LOVE.
[APPLAUSE]
♪
LIVE ON WHAT YOU WOULD, BIG
SMILES.
BIG HEART.
BIG SERVICE, ALL LOVE.
OFFICER SEAN COLLIER WE LOVE
YOU.
THE INSTITUTE CAN BE THE
COMMITTEE TO THINK ABOUT A
MEMORIAL FOR SEAN COLLIER.
THE FIGURE OF THE MEMORIAL IS A
KIND OF FIVE-WALL STRUCTURE
EXTRUDED.
AND THEN A VOID IS ACTUALLY
CARVED OUT OF IT.
AND THAT VOID REPRESENTS A KIND
OF ABSENCE OR LOSS.
THE FORM ITSELF IS BASED ON THE
HAND REPRESENTING BOTH A KIND OF
GESTURE OF OPENNESS TO OTHERS.
BUT ALSO THE ABILITY TO APPLY
ONE'S SELF TO MAKE THINGS
BETTER.
WE WANTED THE STONE TO BE
REPRESENTATIVE OF THE PLACES
WHERE SEAN SPENT A LOT OF TIME,
LIKE THE MIT OUTING CLUB, SO WE
THOUGHT OF GRANITE, NEW
HAMPSHIRE.
THE MEMORIAL IS MADE OF 32
BLOCKS WHICH PIECE TOGETHER IN A
WAY THAT ALLOWS EACH BLOCK TO
HOLD THE OTHER ONE UP.
I WILL GO AROUND AND GET THE
OTHER TWO.
SO IT'S STRENGTH COMES FROM
UNITY.
ITS STRENGTH COMES FROM THE
MANY, AS OPPOSED TO A SINGULAR
STRUCTURE.
PEOPLE DON'T BUILD ANYMORE
THIS WAY.
SO IT'S AN EXPERIMENT IN USING
REALLY OLD-FASHIONED TECHNIQUES
OF STONE MASONRY.
SORT OF PRE-MODEL BUT USING
HIGH-END COMPUTERS FOR THE
SHAPES AND LAY-OUT OF THE
STONES.
WE ARE SAYING THIS IS A-1,
IT'S GREAT, IT'S PERFECT.
THE FIVE WALLS ACTUALLY
EXTEND OUT FROM THE CENTRAL
VOID.
AS THEY EXTEND OUT THEY FRAME
VERY SPECIFIC VIEWS.
THE TWO WALLS CLOSEST
TOGETHER ALIGN WITH A LOCATION
OF SEAN'S CRUISER WHERE HE WAS
SHOT.
IT'S THE MOST INTIMATE SPACE IN
THE MEMORIAL.
WHEN YOU WERE UNDER IT FRAMES
EXACTLY THAT SPOT WHERE THE
TRAGEDY OCCURRED.
WHAT WE REALLY HAVE IS FIVE
HALF ARCHES EACH LEANING IN
TOWARDS THE MIDDLE.
WHILE THAT HALF ARCH SHOULD FALL
OVER, THERE IS ANOTHER HALF ARCH
SOMEWHERE ELSE LEANING IN AND
ANOTHER HALF ARCH, EACH ARE
COMING TOGETHER IN THE MIDDLE.
AND THE FIVE WALLS ARE A
BUTTRESSING THE CENTER PART OF A
VERY PLAT VAULT.
AS THE ARCHES PUSH OUT WARDS ON
THE WALLS, THE WALLS WANT TO
SPREAD OUT, AND BURIED
UNDERGROUND IS A CENTRAL TIE
PULLING TOWARDS THE CENTER AND
PULLING THE WHOLE MEMORIAL
TOGETHER SO IT'S AN EQUILIBRIUM.
AND THERE IS A FORM IN THE
CONCRETE WITH STEEL EMBEDDED IN
THE CONCRETE TO ENSURE THAT THE
WALLS WILL NOT MOVE OUTWARD OVER
THE CENTURIES.
THE OUTSIDE OF THE STRUCTURE
IS A FLAMED SURFACE.
THIS IS A FINE GRAIN AND DENSE
GRANITE, BUT LEAVES A FLAT BUT
MORE TEXTURED SURFACE.
EACH STONE IS CUT WITH
ADVANCED MILLING TECHNOLOGY AND
SOME STONES ARE CUT BY ROBOTS.
AND THE ACCURACY OF EACH STONE
IS WITHIN ONE MILLIMETER.
EVEN AS THE ROBOT IS CARVING
THE BLOCKS, SOMEONE HAS TO TAP
EVERY SINGLE PIECE AND BREAK IT
OFF ONE BY ONE, BEFORE THE ROBOT
CAN COME IN FOR ITS FINAL PASS.
IT WAS A KIND OF INCREDIBLE
DANCE BETWEEN LIKE MACHINE AND
MAN TO CARVE THESE PIECES.
IT'S LIKE A THREE-DIMENSIONAL
JIGSAW PUZZLE WITH FINELY
POLISHED BLOCKS GRANITE.
BUT IN THIS CASE THEY WAY 10,000
EACH.
I AM ROB ROGERS, A PROJECT
MANAGER FOR SUFFOLK CONSTRUCTION
AND ALL SEAN COLLIER'S BROTHER.
THERE A SEQUENCE OF HOW WE LOWER
THE STONES.
THE STONES SHOULD LOCK IN PLACE.
WHEN THE FIRST BLOCKS ARRIVED
AND STARTED TO TAKE PHYSICAL
FORM, AS AN ARCHITECT THAT'S A
MAGICAL MOMENT.
WHEN A CONCEPT TURNS INTO
PHYSICAL REALITY.
THERE WERE MANY TIMES IN THIS
WHOLE PROJECT WHERE WE HAD TO
KEEP OUR EMOTIONS IN CHECK.
BECAUSE IT WAS SUCH AN
EMOTIONAL PROJECT FOR EVERYONE
INVOLVED.
IT'S BEEN A VERY HUMBLING
FEELING, YOU KNOW, IN THE PAST
ALMOST TWO YEARS SINCE SEAN IS
GONE.
IT'S HELPED A LOT.
WE STARTED WITH THE KEYSTONE
AND WE HAD TO BUILD A TEMPORARY
SCALPEL UNDER THAT KEYSTONE AND
THEN THE RING STONES CAME IN
NEXT, AND WE SEQUENTIALLY WENT
THROUGH EACH OF THE FIVE LEGS.
AS PROBABLY THE HARDEST
SEASON TO BUILD IN.
WE HAVE 109 INCHES, WORSE
WINTER EVER IN BOSTON.
IT'S MORE CHALLENGING.
BUT EVERYONE ON SITE WAS GREAT.
WE KNEW WE HAD AN END DATE AND
WE NEED TO MEET THIS DATE.
SO GUYS WORKED HARDER AND
LONGER.
THE MOST EXCITING MOMENT AND
THE MOST CRITICAL MOMENT IN THE
CONSTRUCTION IS WHEN WE LOWERED
THE SCAFFOLDING AND THE KEYSTONE
AND THE VAULT GO INTO THE FIVE
WALLS FOR THE FIRST TIME.
WE HAD INSTRUMENTS FOR
PLACEMENT IF 25 DIFFERENT
LOCATIONS AND SCALES TO DO
REAL-TIME MEASUREMENTS OF HOW
THE LOAD IS TRANSFERRED.
WE WILL START WITH THE THREE
MIDDLE ONES.
AS WE LOWER THE TEMPORARY
SUPPORTS AND THEY COME DOWN, THE
LOAD ON THE SCALE SHOULD COME
DOWN.
AND THE LOAD ON THE SCALES ARE
GOING DOWN BECAUSE THE WEIGHT OF
THE STONES ARE GOING ON ARCHING.
IF WE LOWER THE SUPPORTS AND THE
READING ON THE SCALE DOESN'T
CHANGE, THAT'S BAD.
ONE
TWO
THREE.
WOW, BABY.
THAT'S GREAT.
[APPLAUSE]
SO BEHIND "B" LEG IS A LITTLE
PART OF MY SPEECH THAT I GAVE
FOR SEAN.
SO THEY ENGRAVED IT ON TO THE
STONE.
SO LIVE LONG LIKE HE WOULD, BIG
HEARTS AND BIG SMILES AND BIG
SERVICE, ALL LOVE.
HE WAS A KID THAT LOVED, AND HAD
A MILLION KIDS.
I DON'T KNOW HOW HE SLEPT,
ALWAYS DOING SOMETHING AND
HANGING OUT WITH SOMEBODY.
REALLY LIVED LIFE TO ITS
FULLEST.
HE WAS MADE TO BE A POLICE
OFFICER, I KNOW THAT HIS MOTHER
SAID THAT HE WANTED TO BE A
POLICEMEN FROM THE TIME HE WAS
SEVEN YEARS OLD.
AND IT SHOWED, IT SHOWED IN
EVERYTHING HE DID, HE GOT IT.
IT'S A VERY OPEN STRUCTURE
FOR SOMETHING BUILT OUT OF SUCH
SOLID STONE, AND IT'S TO BE A
GATEWAY INTO CAMPUS.
THERE ARE PEOPLE MILLING AROUND
AND SPEND TIME OUTSIDE.
SO WE HAVE THESE BENCHES AND
THERE WILL BE TREES.
AND IT HOPEFULLY WILL BE A PLACE
THAT HE ENJOYS SITTING DOWN AND
SPENDING TIME WITH THEIR FRIENDS
AND THE COMMUNITY.
I HOPE THAT THE MEMORIAL WILL
BECOME ONE OF THE BELOVED
ELEMENTS ON CAMPUS.
HOPEFULLY IT CAN REMAIN FOR US
TO REMEMBER SEAN'S SERVICE AND
THE COMING TOGETHER OF THE
COMMUNITY.
AND OUR VALUES.
[APPLAUSE]
MEEJIN, JOHN AND ROB, MEMBERS OF
THE PROJECT TEAM AND THE
PERMANENT COLLIER MEMORIAL.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FROM THE
BOTTOM OF MY HEART AND FROM
EVERYONE IN THE COMMUNITY.
I WOULD LIKE TO THANK DR. ERICA
FUNKHOUSER AND OUR STUDENTS FOR
HONORING SEAN WITH THEIR
BEAUTIFUL POEM--THE WORDS TO
WHICH ARE AVAILABLE AT THE
ENTRANCES TO THE TENT--ALL OF
TODAY'S SPEAKERS, BILL CUTTER
AND THE MEMBERS OF MIT'S CHAMBER
CHORUS AND CONCERT CHOIR, AND
OUR COMMUNITY FOR GATHERING TO
DEDICATE THIS EXTRAORDINARY
MEMORIAL WITH THOSE WHO MADE IT
POSSIBLE.
I INVITE YOU NOW TO JOIN ME IN A
MOMENT OF SILENCE TO REMEMBER
OFFICER COLLIER.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE RISE FOR THE BENEDICTION
BY RABBI FISHER AND REMAIN
STANDING FOR THE OPENING OF THE
MEMORIAL, AFTER WHICH, I INVITE
YOU TO JOIN US FOR A COMMUNITY
PICNIC AND TO EXPERIENCE THE MIT
MEMORIAL TO OFFICER COLLIER.
FOR EVERYTHING THERE IS A
SEASON,
A TIME FOR EVERY ACTIVITY UNDER
HEAVEN.
A TIME TO BE BORN AND A TIME TO
DIE.
A TIME TO PLANT AND A TIME TO
PLUCK UP THAT WHICH IS PLANTED.
A TIME TO BREAK DOWN AND A TIME
TO BUILD UP.
A TIME TO WEEP AND A TIME TO
LAUGH.
A TIME TO MOURN AND A TIME TO
DANCE.
A TIME TO SCATTER STONES AND A
TIME TO GATHER STONES.
A TIME TO EMBRACE AND A TIME TO
REFRAIN FROM EMBRACING.
A TIME TO SEEK AND A TIME TO
LOSE.
A TIME TO KEEP AND A TIME TO
CAST AWAY.
A TIME TO TEAR AND A TIME TO
MEND.
EXCERPTED FROM ECCLESIASTES 3.
AS WE HAVE ALREADY HEARD TODAY,
DURING THESE PAST TWO YEARS, WE
HAVE RUN THE GAMUT OF THESE ACTS
AND EMOTIONS.
THE ATTACK AT THE MARATHON, AND
THE MURDER OF OFFICER COLLIER
SHOOK US -- SHOOK BOSTON,
CAMBRIDGE, MIT.
WE LEARNED HOW VULNERABLE WE
ARE, SO MORE THAN WE IMAGINED.
WE LEARNED ABOUT HATE, BASELESS
HATRED THAT COULD TAKE LIVES,
INCLUDING THE LIFE OF ONE SO
DEVOTED, SO CHEERFUL, AND SO
FULL OF CARE.
AND, WE ALSO LEARNED WE ARE
STRONGER THAN WE EVER IMAGINED.
WE CAME TOGETHER AS A COMMUNITY;
WE STOOD STRONG.
HEROES LIKE SEAN GAVE US
REMINDERS OF COMPASSION,
DEDICATION, KINDNESS; AN EXAMPLE
OF HOW TO BE PART OF A
COMMUNITY, HOW TO BUILD
COMMUNITY, HOW TO CARE FOR A
COMMUNITY.
AND, WE HAVE BUILT AND REBUILT
OUT OF THESE EVENTS, THESE
MEMORIES.
O GOD, CONTINUE TO BE WITH US AS
WE BUILD, AND CONTINUE TO LET US
KNOW YOU ARE NEAR.
O GOD, LET US LIVE IN PEACE.
HELP US.
TEACH ALL PEOPLE OF ALL
NATIONALITIES, RACES, AND
FAITHS, IN ALL COUNTRIES -- IN
ALL CITIES, HERE AND ALL OVER
THE WORLD, TO BELIEVE THAT
PEACE, THAT SECURITY, WHICH
OFTEN SEEM SO FAR OFF, ARE, IN
FACT, WITHIN IN OUR REACH.
OBSTRUCT THE PLANS OF ANY
PLOTTING TO DO HARM TO ANOTHER.
WATCH OVER US, GOD; WATCH OVER
THIS MEMORIAL.
WATCH OVER SEAN COLLIER'S FAMILY
AND FRIENDS.
WATCH OVER YOUR WORLD.
SHELTER US ALL WITH PEACE.
SEAN, YOUR LIFE WAS
EXTINGUISHED, BUT YOUR LIGHT CAN
NEVER BE EXTINGUISHED.
IT SHINES ON ALL OF US AND
ILLUMINATES OUR WAYS.
YOU ARE WITH US ALWAYS.
WE WILL NOT FORGET YOU.
AS THIS MEMORIAL SERVES AS A
PHYSICAL SIGN, REMINDING US OF
YOU, AND OF YOUR VALUES:
MAY WE ALL STRIVE WITH ALL OUR
MIGHT TO LIVE UP TO THE EXAMPLE
YOU HAVE SET.
MAY WE STRIVE TO FACE EACH DAY
WITH EAGERNESS.
TO VALUE OUR COMMUNITIES AND OUR
FRIENDS.
TO TRY TO SEE A FRIEND IN EACH
NEW PERSON WE ENCOUNTER.
MAY WE SEEK TO GUARD OTHERS, AS
YOU GUARDED US.
MAY YOUR MEMORY BE WITH US ALONG
ALL OUR PATHS AND OUR WAYS.
WATCH OVER US, GOD.
WATCH OVER SEAN.
WATCH OVER YOUR WORLD.
SHELTER US ALL WITH PEACE, WITH
LOVE, NOW AND ALWAYS.
AND LET US SAY, AMEN.